I was born Elizabeth Oliva de Santa
Monica Hospital 1995 December 5th so my
birthday's just now thank you turn 24
know my dad he he he live rock star
lifestyle he and he actually was a you
know you know bopping around this area
throughout my childhood he was down in
the row you know my father wasn't in my
life because he was um black tar heroin
sales men for the Hells Angels the Hells
Angels I had him employed as a heroin
salesman from since before I was born so
I'm viewing you know Bop around here
they're everywhere all over Los Angeles
he was from San Fernando Valley so I
mean he was in my life but you know not
too heavily because of that but um yeah
my mom she raised me um and she
remarried when I was four to a man who
she had two other children with I felt
as if I was maybe a third parent to
these girls they were twins so um you
know I felt like I got to raise my two
little sisters to an extent and so um
the age 17
from then on I was on my own my dad died
when I was 14 he died of a heroin
overdose and that left me with a sort of
morbid curiosity for the drug you know I
eventually ended up trying it around 18
19 20 and it was my jam it was pretty
sweet nothing else like it feeling is
like how it's like to be loved to feel
content like when you're going up a
roller coaster up up up up right at that
top of the roller coaster
so whooshing huh that's the rush like
it's also imagine you're you're you're
going down that rush into a warm bath
with a hot cup a cup of cocoa and say
you know just feeling a warm wrapped in
bliss everything's cool even if
everything beforehand was nightmare you
know meltdown
horrible nothing was going right after
you do that you know Thanks
everything's cool nothing can bother the
rubbish itself last me a few minutes um
the the state of bliss you know I feel
content for you know a couple hours the
the body high itself which is kind of
like a mellow sort of almost almost like
a THC high like you know a body high
where I feel uh you know painless and
you know relaxed I used a push back if
you say it like that that would probably
last me about four to six hours and then
I'll start jonesing and feeling the
aches and the cramps and edginess
edginess kicks in first which is a sort
of feeling of needing to stretch stretch
and stretch but never feeling the
satisfaction from the stretch but you
think that going like this you'd feel
good okay you got those muscles stretch
though they still feel
just as edgy it's like having an itch
you scratch it and it's still just as
itchy and that'll keep you rolling
around in your bed all night if you
don't get that fixed well I'd say I'm
like with you know speeders maybe like
ecstasy that first high is what people
chase no oh no it's never the same but
the heroin hype stays pretty consistent
yeah it's a you know you get the right
amount
you got you dosage right it's um
usually just as good as the first time
around I mean it doesn't really uh um
you know deviate from that that first go
so I mean that's what keeps me coming
back yeah it's uh it's a hell of a drug
hmm I really liked being a small kid um
Riley age three probably some like
funnest little memories hanging out with
my dad and you know right there on the
beach used to live right um on the shore
and the Palisades you know put me on his
shoulders and walk me down to the pier
play arcade games I remember a birthday
actually when I was three or he took me
to the pier and he won me teddy bears
and stuff and remember the end of the
day my mom gave him a bunch of [__]
about how he you know threw down some
more cash for some toys r us toys or
something or more of a high tech high
ticket like item you know then just you
know arcade prize and I could sense the
the guilt trip he was being put through
and the fact they didn't have enough
- - to get what he wanted to get from me
for my birthday and I figured in my head
hey that that jumbo teddy bear he won
for me I don't need it as much as he
does he he I think he needs that a
little bit more than I do here it's like
dad you should keep the teddy bear I'm
he she's really putting you through a
number right now you need it more than I
do
and you know I remember just like
there's a lot of Tears you know I could
I could understand he was trying his
best I can always relate to my dad more
mm well um I will bounce from Skid Row
to to Venice Beach usually when I need
to wind down and just you know enjoy the
ocean and just relax and get away from
the hectic craziness not as easily as I
can here so that's why it's kind of fun
I feel kind of sort of tethered to this
area but I mean it's possible but it's
tricky I've been clean for a few months
here and there um a few times yeah
ben'll um well my concern is with
fentanyl are a little bit different than
the average person's the fentanyl has
become somewhat of a popular drug with
the younger heroin users actually in
Venice Beach there's certain areas where
you go there trying to find maybe a dime
bag of them black black tar and uh they
won't have they won't have it you can
ask him a dozen or so people um you know
salesman and all he's got is fentanyl
it's a gun that popular um that you know
it's it's it's the preferred drug of
choice there there's different kinds now
there's pink champagne fentanyl there's
cotton candy fentanyl fentanyl maternes
uh orange when you light it on the foil
and then green and then yellow it's
really well what I'll do is I'm a
booster I've been a booster for a while
I learned how to boost in downtown
downtown boosters boost almost for sport
it's a competitive thing we try and flex
on each other see who can get the most
you know like high-end big ticket items
this sort of you know show off to each
other and see
the periphery of Skid Row or you go into
other neighborhood Skid Row mm-hmm
Skid Row technically starts I'd say
around Los Angeles Street Los Angeles
Rinat no one booths in any stores
they're boosters that University will
agree
no one booths from Los Angeles the those
those vendors are protected all the
stores are all the liquor stores
protected Los Angeles and up to figure
Ella and beyond you
yeah Beverly Center you know Valley
anywhere is it's totally you know
free-for-all yeah you can go it's places
that are you know insured
he'll Macy sorry gay Walgreens Rite Aid
CVS you name it those places are the
spots thing you know people will make
their living they they take those items
and they usually have certain items that
are known to be popular items to sell
and they bring them to a person who to
fence the fence is a person who buys the
stolen objects and that person will give
you cash that person doesn't deal in
drugs that person doesn't even do drugs
that person just gives you straight cash
for whatever items you bring well a lot
of the times when Alexa's store and then
they've got their eye on me I will bring
a big tote as a kind of fake out and
that's I'll just have you know whatever
I would normally carry and so when they
look in it and easily see there's
nothing you know stolen but what I do is
um you know Oh keep merchandise you know
I'm a person inside in pockets like you
know you
like I'll tuck in my shirt with a tight
belt and I'll put it in the back of the
collar in the front of the collar
I'll put things like into my sleeve
you know I've I've gone so far as to you
know I hit you know put things and hats
yeah those people do receipts it's a
little bit different but that's
something that's very popular their
receipts yeah yeah I don't want to do
that too much but yeah that's a good way
of going about it it's a little safer
but they do catch on you can't just keep
doing that over and over yeah stores
stores that learn your faces and I think
certain stores passed around photos of
people you know they got a roster of
boosters and they'll don't recognize
your face because your photo has been
shared you know with the other stores no
that's one thing um i don't stoop to
that I wouldn't if I already feel that
level I don't think I would be
comfortable doing the drug I do I was at
that point I feel that I would have lost
my dignity yeah as of today from 24 you
know I'm trying to get in contact with
my little sisters um uh yeah I haven't I
haven't heard from my family in a minute
I've food to my uncle a year ago I was
in contact with him and it was hanging
out with him for a moment actually um
it's pretty interesting he found me at
Venice Beach I met him one time at my
dad's funeral I met him and so when he
found me on the beach he's telling me
hey Livi it's me your uncle Patrick I
just got out of a pin I heard you're on
the streets I robbed three banks and I
came and found you
I got you a gram of your black so don't
trip wherever your things are just
forget my homegirls gonna hook you up
with whatever you need
just come with me to the valley so
that's my did and we were in in the
valley a happy family for about a week
until a u.s. marshal came and raided the
hotel room and they took him away he
actually was pretty ballsy he robbed
three banks in one intersection he
robbed one across the street and then um
while the [__] the first robbery was
being responded to by the police the the
second bank was being robbed across the
street and thus the third Bank after
that was being robbed while the second
bank was being responded to by the
police and he said yeah you got away
with that for a minute
and he's a very light blond hair guy
he's got white blond hair and what he
were doing is you put the red kool-aid
up in his hair and his beard red
kool-aid and online I called him the
ginger bandit
I turned to brannad like red hair so
when they detained me and the man Cole
the detectives asked me how are you
related to this incident man I said I
don't know what incident you're talking
about I don't know why I'm being
detained I'm related to this guy right
here he's my uncle we had the same last
name I met him last week who the they're
like sounds highly unlikely we believe
you we just want you to tell us um we
got this picture of your uncle
I can you tell me who the picture of is
who is the man in this photograph is you
know him in the bank and I look at it
and like you think that's my uncle now
because this guy's got a toy different
hair color that's not my uncle because
they couldn't be he's got a completely
different hair color there all right
thanks man this is awesome that's all I
need so they ended up taking him and
done this story gets even deeper you
ready
this is all fact so I mean we're ready
for this one
that night I get back to the room
waiting for his homegirl to get released
from the questioning and they
immediately are suspicious of me wanting
to take the car he drove around they
were not hmm not the funnest people to
get along with
they were junkies as well they were kind
of abrasive and I think they sense the
fact that he had told me the car he rode
around in was mine if you were to be
popped he told me that and I wanna think
about him going away but you know when
he did it hurt in a very similar way to
when my father passed I didn't expect it
to hurt me like that but when he was
gone I was oh I know that feeling it's
just like who's him dad he was just like
my dad you know he's his brother and he
was looking out for me like my dad and I
miss him just like I miss my dad when he
died I hurts and I was hoping to go to
them for some kind of comfort or you
know you know some kind of consolation
but they were talking about cavity
searching me for the car keys because
like I'm not taking the car blah blah
blah and I hadn't even said anything
about taking the car I thought they had
the keys I see the security guard pacing
the the hallways in the parking lot and
so I try and go a little bit ahead of
him but on the first floor I see three
pieces of luggage strewn about plop plop
plop not in any particular order
just randomly dropped out drive drop and
one of them is a briefcase it looks
almost like a Looney Tunes cartoon and
this rupees is half open half closed and
the other side is sticking money I grab
the money and just a little bit I go to
the stairwell just to count it out I'm
thinking it's fake I think it's like a
joke this this briefcase isn't even in
front of one door it's like just
diagonally across the hallway thank you
for
couple doors so I'm kind as money in the
stairwell just shaking like feeling like
sweating like scared out of my mind it's
100 200 300 400 500 600 and I realize
it's all hundred-dollar bills and I'm
just terrified maybe somebody saw me
it's about 2:00 a.m. I go back I grab
the whole briefcase after what felt like
an eon and I run up to my uncle's
friends room and knock on the door
frantically let me let me in let me in
let me in they have a piece of paper
over the peephole
I see it move ahead pop in a look oh
they see me and they move their head
back put the piece of paper over it and
nothing a radio silence no Libby allowed
obviously I got no response which they
later I'm sure they later found out was
that probably the wrong move on their
part because I took the briefcase to a
nearby alley popped it open found six
thousand dollars in cash a block of
heroin about this big this thick you
know this wide probably it was just like
yeah like that big and a big bag of
fentanyl like sandwich bag so I'm sure
over $10,000 worth of like at least of
dope money and so those on the street at
all that night and the first dude who
you know drives by me kind of slows down
and took me out I wrote to the car say
hey try me drive me downtown here's $100
so is judaising downtown dropped me off
and I find a family friends house to
stash the side and the cupboard and I
would you know break off anyone anyone
whoever coming right when I was dope
stick in the past if I was dope stick
they gave me a cotton rinse you know a
little smidgen I gave him back a c-note
and you know like huge wad of Parowan
just to you know show my gratefulness
that they had my back when I needed them
and you know you should people can
attest for that yeah yes indefinitely
and I haven't forgotten so that's that's
good yeah I made sure I broke off who
ever cared about me at all in the past
and um yeah I was very very like
generous with it and I had her for a few
months someone eventually stole it for
me which was a relief because the people
who were closest to me my very tight as
the friends were you know like trying to
trying to just weasel their way into
like I would have to go and wait at the
apartment building next door to the one
where my family friend lived because I
would see them like waiting dis
aggressive me like I'm stalking me to
try and come in and steal it and it was
just terrifying I didn't know who to
trust and people were telling me lies so
you know sent me in the wrong direction
all the time source of faint baloney
like scare tactics so when it was gone I
knew who had it and I could have gone
and you know claimed it but I just let
them have it that person had it two days
I had a few months he had two days and
people who had after told me hey oh that
that's that's the that was from you that
all I don't but then yeah it came from
you did you know there was a full-sized
hammer like a tool hammer inside the
dope and I didn't even know I hadn't
gotten that far into it to find a
full-size hammer inside the dope to
weigh it down and I had been taking such
huge chunks out of it almost every day
for months that's how big of a piece of
dope I found yeah it was fun while it
lasted hopefully I'll come up again and
maybe I'll call it a day but if not you
know I'll uh you know I'll go out and
style
thank you so much for talking to me
absolutely it was nice to share my story